all right maddie yeah maddie where you
from originally where did you grow up
i grew up in walnut creek california up
north
yeah bay area and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young
well i'm adopted and i was taken at
birth
and um so i went into foster care
and my um
i was hit throughout foster care so my
adopted mom got me
originally there was a couple that came
along and wanted to adopt me but
i was too sick i had ear infections that
were killing me
and when my adopted mom got me um
she took me into the doctors and got me
surgery on my ears because i needed two
replacements um so
i dealt with
[Music]
being a traumatized child from the
beginning of birth
from your first foster family yeah i
think i went from foster family to
foster family i think it was in like
maybe five to 10 different homes as even
before i was even two
because i kept coughing all the time
instead of like taking me to doctors
they would just hit me to shut me up
so eventually you ended up with a family
that was stable and um i ended up
getting they put me i was in a like they
were looking for a family to adopt me
and a lot of like the first family
didn't want to adopt me because i was
sick
i was so sick and they said oh a sick
child we don't want this child
and then um
after that um i my mom
my adopted mom came along and um
she she adopted me because she really
loved babies
but she didn't love like the part of the
person growing up
because it was her losing control she
wanted to feel wanted
but she she adopted me took me to the
doctor
got my ears fixed and i i was deaf until
i was about two
so i had no speech no hearing no nothing
i just
kind of i learned it really late so in
school i went to speech for about eight
years
and um i couldn't say things like basic
words like
computer or napkin or napkin or
paper towels or you know it was just a
re
it was it was a fresh start to learn how
to talk
but just late um
and then um
she raised me um as a single mother
adopted me a single mother um at the
time i had
two parents but he wasn't actually my
parent he was just around when i was
adopted
so it became like my father he was my
father though
he wasn't my adopted father my blood
father but he was family
and family is really important to me
i remember that after
i was probably like five years old
my mom kicked him out because he was an
alcoholic because she wanted to control
him
my mom had severe control issues and so
i went through like the abandonment of
two parents separating
and uh that was really really difficult
for me
um and then after that i was
um my mom like
these two guys came to our house and was
like this guy has nowhere to stay can he
stay with you
and that was the beginning of my
childhood rape
um i went four years of being starved
four years of being hit with metal bar
four years
of being hit with a horse whip four
years of sexually
mis um rape sexual rape
four years of being locked in a room
four years of being tied to a bed
four years of just childhood trauma that
can't be taken back
but it's made me who i am today um
it got my mom ended up finding someone
she wanted to marry
and um with this guy i just remember i
would be
he would he treated me like i was a doll
to him like
i was something he could put in the
bathtub and shave my legs
um get angry and hit me when he wanted
he would he would like
do all kinds of nasty sexual play
after i was done with like even before
school like
remember before kindergarten he'd take
me to the gas station
and he would like pick up magazines of
trans women
and show and trans men and show me at
that age
and he showed me what my first vibrating
dildo was at five i remember i walked
into school and i was telling other kids
what a vibrator was like a dildo
because i didn't understand why i would
get in trouble
and i went in and they said you can't
say that kind of stuff or i'll have to
suspend you
but like where were the teachers
thinking like why would a kid be saying
that did they ask any questions
i remember i went to school one day and
i told the teacher
hey look i'm being i'm being touched i'm
being hit
and they checked my body and they didn't
see any bruises so they had sent me home
with the guy that was doing it to me
and that guy ended up telling me
and if i told anybody that he would
take my mom and me hang me from a tree
cut her open in front of me
and then cut me open and i would have to
watch her bleed
um this this was
your adopted mom's boyfriend yeah
this this was just the beginning and
this this started
the sexual part of it started when you
were about five
probably like the beginning of five four
five
um so i went from that to my step dad
moving in
whole new guy right and um
i remember that he wasn't a bad guy
um but tension started because i
remember that
the first night was great but after that
first guy that
the guy that abused me my mom brought
around i promised myself i would always
hate my stepdad
i'd always hate him i always look like
at him as he's evil
as he's a bad man and um
he wasn't a bad man i learned as
i got older my mom manipulated me in his
situation to see it as
something it wasn't because she would
get jealous that he would take me out
shopping and it wasn't her
and she'd pick fights between us and it
was manipulating because we both didn't
see it that way
and i realized if i had given him a
chance and that hadn't happened he
would be different in my life but it
came to the point where it was like
i made him so angry and he made me so
angry he'd get violent with me
like i remember in elementary school he
would pick me up and push me against the
wall and shake me
and i told the school and they told him
he can't do that anymore so he stopped
um and it went from that to like
him looking down my shirt and i was
afraid like maybe he would rape me
or maybe he would poison me because he
wanted my mom
and i just experienced a lot of jealousy
between my stepdad and my mom
and
i i think my mom was married with him
for 14 years
and when i was 12 um
when i was 12 the guy that was at the
house that treated me like his daughter
not the rapist when i was in the house
they were selling drugs out of it it was
a drug house
especially and i remember this one guy
he was
he wasn't he was pretty sober he smoked
cigarettes and
um he took care of me he showed me my
first computer what nickelodeon was we'd
go outside and
like i was a kid i loved insects i like
to collect butterflies and
and um ladybugs what kid doesn't
and i remember when i was 12 i remember
that i got a call
from the cops my mom did and i was in
the car and they said to me
that he had killed himself and i
remember that i asked
myself i always loved him why wouldn't
he come and told me that he like cared
about me
i would have been there for him i would
have always
cared about him i was always i've always
been and still am the girl with the good
heart that would be there for a friend
an instant if they were
[ __ ] up or trying to kill themselves
or commit suicide i would be that one
person i'd run wild
to like get on the plane just to fly to
them
but i just remember like i couldn't
believe the one person that took care of
me through all that trauma was gone
so that was really that was really just
made me upset um and after that
um my mom started taking in like
people that were like homeless and that
like couldn't take care of themselves
and wouldn't take care of themselves my
mom thought she could fix them
every guy that she's ever brought around
has been more important than her
daughter
and she felt like she could fix them she
could fix
anybody and what she wasn't realizing is
she was damaging her own daughter
she adopted me for whatever reasons
to not care that i was special not care
that i had needs not care
that i was a human a person living in
this world from a young child
and those men that she was bringing
around were damaging me
hurting me in ways that
no child no no child at all should go
through rape
no child all should go through abuse no
child at all should be neglected from
their food
or their rib cage is showing
any child not a foster care child not
children deserve better and adults
sometimes deserve better
but it
after after the whole situation with
him killing himself my childhood rape
childhood past
and my stepdad um
by the time i was
14 um i was
well even before that um
i was on online dating sites because i
didn't feel safe to be in my own home at
this point
i was jumping from house to house
sleeping at random people's house just
so i felt safe i felt safe with iran
more i felt more safe with a random
person
than i did at my own home
and then one time i got on there and i
started
looking to seek help from like finding
somebody to sleep at their house
i was kidnapped for a week the guy
drugged me up
he was going to take me to mexico and
then
the cop showed up at his house and said
we tracked you
where is this girl at ask me if they
knew the girl
because obviously they knew that he had
taken me
and then he dropped me off in front of
my house and i went inside and crawled
to bed because i was on
i was on oxycontin he drugged me up i've
never been on drugs before i've never
done weed i've never drinking
it getting oxycontin and he gave me
xanax and i just remember i passed out
and he was having sex with me and he was
probably like 27 years old and i was 14.
and i just remember being gone for a
week and being drugged up
and being out of it and um
it was hard um
and then after that i went to a boarding
school a wilderness program my parents
sent me away
they woke me up at five three a.m in the
morning to
two big black women a black woman and a
black man coming in
and taking me at 3am in the morning
and all i could think is why are two
people taking me
early in the morning
it wouldn't even matter what color they
are like could be two
big white people and i'd be scared like
i just got i just got kidnapped and my
mom's paying
three
my mom's paying these people to come
take me and i'm like thinking
who the [ __ ] is she who is she paying
to come take me at 3 am in the morning
i thought i was gonna be sex trafficked
at that point
that my parents were conned or something
so i'm waking up at 3am in the morning
taken to a white van
like those vans used it's called the sex
trafficking vans the pedophile vans
put in there and get told i'm taking
being put on a plane and going somewhere
they wouldn't tell me where
and i'm thinking to myself like
[ __ ] what's gonna happen with my life
well i ended up in a wilderness program
about six months ago i was outdoors i
backpacked i
hiked i went trailing and
i loved it all actually i didn't want to
leave i didn't want to go back to
society i didn't want to be a part of
society
i loved being outdoors so much that i
felt at home
i was nice and so
i did that and then i went to a boarding
school and i uh would run from these
sporting schools because i felt forced
to be somewhere i didn't want to be
i don't let people force me to be where
i don't want to be
it's not who i am i'm my own goddamn
person
and um so i just ran away
um
i guess after these boarding schools i
um well
i ended up what i was going to say is i
ended up taking um a car
i was i i ran away from the boarding
school i ended up
finding someone's house that wasn't
there and i went took the car and i
drove back to california
from idaho because i felt that i'd never
driven a car before
i didn't have any directions i didn't
have a map i didn't know
i didn't even know i could navigate but
i just got in a car and i drove it
i drove it back to california an hour
away from getting where i
wanted to go i was almost to freedom
i got caught i got pulled over and
they're like hey
we have to take you to juvie and i was
honest i was like i don't have a permit
or anything and i was like okay well
you can arrest me now because i'm not
supposed to be driving this car
and um so
i went to julie and then my parents were
like we gotta come get her
she must be at a boarding school brought
me back up there and i tried to run
again
like when the the spot was when i got to
a gas station i tried to run again
i didn't get away but then the detective
actually
um they asked me bring me down the
police station because they needed me to
talk to a detective
and so i went down to the police station
and i told him the honest truth
and then when it went to court i was
just honest about it i
i in the car the the judge actually
looked at me and was like
why are your parents putting you in a
boarding school you're way too smart for
this it's like
you can get out of and do something like
that we don't really hear about cases
like this it's very rare that us
that we have an intelligent girl that
can out they do that kind of stuff
and maybe your parents shouldn't be
putting you in programs like this
because we don't need like cases like
this
it's just um so
uh after that i went down to a lockdown
facility
it was called cinnamon hills and
they were really disturbing they i
feel like that what they did was like
rape
they would take these kids once a month
these girls and these guys
i think it was the girls i don't know
about the guys who separate us but
they'd take us into a doctor and they
would like
say that we needed inspections every
month
and they'd stick their the doctor would
say stuff like oh here comes the rubber
ducky spread your legs
from east to west i'm gonna stick my
fingers up you now
every month he would penetrate her
vaginas with his fingers and fill around
and it was creepy and weird and they
wouldn't let us go see a normal doctor
we had to see the one that they chose
for us we're allowed to go off for maybe
just a dentist um
but it was crazy and then
what was i gonna say um
i think that was like being there they
would like had a lot of mentally ill
people
and um i was not one of them
i would watch people do crazy stuff but
i would be quiet and just watching and
observe
if you got in trouble though they would
like take you and rip your arms out
basically like this and they'd bend you
over
until you scream and you pee yourself
and they'd scream in your face and
traumatize
each person these were underage children
they were doing this to
this was in utah and they would just
scream in your face and these people are
here for
trauma but they would use that against
them
and so i was like really bad to see that
that's the way that
people treat people like and the and
whoever was running that would allow
that to happen
um but as i graduated from that school i
went to another school and
started doing better um
the one thing that was crazy is that
since i was like five
um my teacher said oh she's adhd put her
on meds they put me on adderall i think
it was actually at four years old i was
on adderall
and it really mentally messed me up
really early
and then i went on like from med to med
to med to men to med
every man had a negative side effect my
mom never listened to me about like how
that affected me
it was really awful and so
i finally when i was out of the boarding
schools
and i went through all that [ __ ] i ended
up
taking myself off of it i remember that
feeling of i actually felt like i was
myself
i was a person i haven't been on med
sense i don't touch drugs
i don't touch meds i like being who i am
i'm comfortable with myself
and i feel confident within myself
because i don't
let anything control me that doesn't
need to control me
not a person not drugs not people i am
able to do what i want to do in life
and know that i'm happy with myself
i could walk out with my hair all [ __ ]
up and not care
what people have to say because it's me
i'm just me
do you have a problem with that that's
your own problem that's your own
self-projection
maybe you're worried about how your hair
looks out but that doesn't mean i'm you
so that's how i was and then
after that boarding school i came home
and
i met this guy named harris
and he was working at the store um
actually across from my store
you're how old though i'm 20 i think i'm
20 years old
and i'm home and i'm working at safeway
and this guy worked at nob hill
and um
it was crazy because
he
we were friends we weren't dating or
anything
we're like friends and um i remember
going on these days with them everything
was fine
um remember like in a relationship
relationship at least i didn't think
um but i remember that he
he was really nice to me i really liked
him
and um i remember that he invited me to
go up to
his parents house and at his parents
house
he forcefully raped me by sticking his
dick down my throat
and he wouldn't stop i pushed him off
and he wouldn't stop and
like two years later i think i was like
20 maybe 23.
i found out he raped two other girls
after me
um
at the same time and all those girls are
afraid to say something
honestly it's like that what that guy
did was awful
after one girl after another girl after
another girl
and now he's in the military but
honestly like
he doesn't deserve to be in doing
anything like
i don't know it's not my life though but
um it was the first time that i really
had ptsd
i really was traumatized [ __ ] up
and i just couldn't i couldn't
i was numb i couldn't get a bed for six
months i couldn't
i couldn't live i didn't feel like i
could live but i was living
i was damaged
but not unfixable damage just damage to
like where
it affected me for a long time i was
sleepwalking
i was waking up traumatized so waking up
with nightmares
i was still in i was uh
just so so [ __ ] up
still i sat there i didn't take drugs to
get over it i sat there and i coped with
it
as well as i could it's the first time
i've been raped since my childhood
and then i was brought back all the
flashbacks of everything
um
but i didn't i hadn't at the time
i ended up i was with somebody i
ended up getting with some my ex well he
was my ex-boyfriend because i dated him
for four years
from like 11 to 15.
and then so i ended up getting back with
him at the time and
he ended up calling the cops or i did
call the cops but he stood by my side
through it
and like helped me through it and stuff
and i just remember that
after that was over i remember i ended
up getting drunk for the first time with
him and his friend
um their names were colby and dylan and
um
and my he ended up putting adderall in
my alcohol
and drugged me um 14 years of knowing
someone maybe a little less you're
supposed to trust them
the one the person that stuck through
the rape case with me
not even the case i didn't go to court
or anything but
ended up raping me and his friends raped
me and the only reason i knew is because
i woke up with fingertips on my legs
and hand prints palm prints on my hips
from that
i'll never forget that the one person i
loved to one person that cared about
one person i was in a relationship with
the one person i trusted
did what he did and just acted like it
never
happened and went on with his life like
wasn't even that he acted like it didn't
happen
he knew he was guilty and couldn't say
sorry
and own up to it because he's a [ __ ]
coward
and that's all i see in that person is
like
he knew i loved him and when we broke up
i wasn't willing to go back to being his
girlfriend right away
so he lost his power so he'd get his
power back by raping me
by abusing me
wanted power over me and i know that
colby i heard went to parties and raped
people but the other guy wasn't like
that
and maybe influenced him to do it or
something i don't know
but all i do know is that it was
it was bad because i went from one rape
to another but the next rape was my best
friend
but after that i i ended up feeling like
i was stronger and that i could move on
faster
that time maybe i just was so damaged by
the first one the second one wasn't as
bad
but after that i um
i ended up i think
getting with someone else for about
three years
like two and a half and
i fell in love with that guy and he was
his name is steven
he was a really good guy had a lot of
problems
i accepted those problems but
it was like he
lied too much he couldn't be honest
it didn't matter how much you tried to
work with him he just
himself got in the way
so after three years we broke up
i got with someone else which i was
wasted for months but
i think it was a month or two and the
first time i've known this guy
um because the other guy i didn't think
i could get like we were i wasn't using
birth control we weren't using condom
for three years and um
he he didn't get me pregnant so i
thought maybe i'm infertile
maybe because he said he was an
infertile so i thought i was infertile
and then i came to find out in my next
relationship on the first night i got
pregnant
i was definitely fertile there's nothing
wrong with me
and um
i told them like when we had sex like we
there's possibility i could get pregnant
probably should use a condom but if you
don't want to find
well i end up getting pregnant and he
ran and he was like
i wouldn't mind getting you pregnant and
then that's how that started so it's
like
i made a stupid decision and but now i
have a daughter
so my daughter is [ __ ] great but
besides the point um he ran he was never
there for me during my pregnancy
abandoned me
he
i remember he came to the sonogram and
he told me
that he wishes he had given me a plan b
after seeing his daughter alive and
moving
he wished that he had never he wished he
had killed her
after seeing life
i saw in my head like you're sick
but i just let that slide i didn't
really like say much to it because there
wasn't much to say to that but
i um after that
i found out that my dad was dying from
cancer
um he had stage four pancreatic cancer
and then after that i was kicked out by
my mom
she left a note on the door saying that
you're no longer welcome back here at
six months pregnant
love y'all not i love you love ya if you
need any
she wouldn't even let me get my stuff i
had to call the cops to go back up and
get some few items that i
needed and
she blamed me for her divorce what she
calls herself she controlled his money
she
she dug herself a whole and on top of
that
he wasn't happy he cheated on her with
her high school friend which wasn't okay
on his part either
they both did wrong but
they didn't communicate or talk about it
and
it was like horrible but i remember i
remember i was standing up for my mom so
hardcore
literally not seeing that she was
manipulated it took me getting kicked
out to see the true
my true mom so after that it was like
i was kicked out now i'm six months
pregnant about to be homeless
she stole all my money at three thousand
dollars saved up
so all my money
and kicked me out i supposed to go to a
homeless shelter
don't have a ride there don't have any
clothes don't have anything
luckily i was dating a guy for like a
weekend
him and his mom took me in and
um i stayed with him for a while
um
and it was really hard because i was
very vulnerable
like i did a lot of that person did a
lot of hurt
and i was gaslighted a lot
and i was raped and he said that it was
because
he was drunk and he couldn't remember
and i questioned that
um but i try to talk to him about it
later
he just justifies it like nothing
happened so even talking to him about it
they couldn't do that it was impossible
i mean i loved the guy but it was
impossible
he helped deliver my baby so it took me
in when i was homeless so
was it that i wanted to be there still
and
or was it that i felt entitled to be
there because he helped me out through
the hardest moments
because i'm supposed to be loyal to
people that helped me out
but it was hard
because i don't want to make him mad or
make him feel upset
because it was always so bad big to have
screaming matches
but i ended up getting my own place
and then i made the mistake of after
that place going back to my mom's house
for a little bit
and i realized she got too much so i
packed up my stuff and i took a bus down
to la
i moved down to la and i was down in l.a
for a while
and i didn't know if i was gonna place i
put my daughter in a car seat
packed two suitcases got on the bus and
left
took a leap from faith into the unknown
i didn't know if it was gonna have place
to know
what was gonna happen but i had faith
that like i'd be okay
when i got there i found a room for rent
and i made it
and now
[Music]
i got my permit for the first time
i have my own place now that no one can
take from me
i
just i'm doing better than i ever have
in my life
and i started uh
i just started to feel safe comfortable
and for the first time i felt like i was
at peace that i didn't have to worry
about
abusive boyfriends bad friends
bad parents because now i have the
freedom to cut out anybody that doesn't
serve my purpose in life
that was a goddamn that was a blessing
for me
to realize i'm an adult and i have power
over my life
and how old are you 24.
took me 24 years and everything i've
ever done in my life everything that's
ever happened to me
i did it alone nobody was there for me
not friends not family nobody
maybe my friend alyssa showed up at the
hospital to help me but
through the pregnant scene she's always
kind of been there for me but through
the tough [ __ ] i was alone
it seems like so many people in your
life have let you down
in different ways there is one actually
specific situation that i was really
[ __ ] up more than anything i think
this was worse than rape
when i was after um i broke up
with that guy i got with a guy named
um he was really cool he was a tattoo
artist
i admired his art i thought it was
beautiful i thought he was a beautiful
person
i didn't know at the time of starting to
date him
that he was a methane heroin addict
i
i uh the only reason i found out was
because
he went over to a girl's house and i
didn't know where he was i thought he
was cheating or something
then he came back he's like no i'm a
functional drug addict and i'm like
[ __ ] he rides a motorcycle perfectly
fine he works a 40-hour job i would
never have known like
i don't deal with people a lot that do
drugs or i don't even deal with them
but it was crazy because i i wouldn't
think that he could function like that
like someone on drugs can function and
he did a really good job
functioning on drugs
and then i found out later that i was
pregnant
by him
i ended up um
i ended up um
i ended up getting a call from a little
cop show up and told me how to leave his
property
ended up getting a call from his lawyer
basically his
lawyer was trying to force an abortion
on me trying to say they would take me
to court to like
force an abortion and
and then he would do all these
say nasty things and then they're like
we'll pay you a lot of money
we'll pay for your abortion we'll do
this we'll do that like
um
i didn't felt like my free will was
taken away from me
but like maybe that's what he wanted was
to
hurt me in that way
because maybe i had hurt him but he
wanted to
really destroy me
so when i went to the boston
um i went through it alone
i remember that i saw the baby live
next when i saw the baby dead it was
really traumatizing for me think that's
the last
trump time to see the situation that
i've been through
and i don't think that guy will ever
ever know
the damage he did to my life and him
being a methane heroin addict
should know that things can [ __ ] up your
life and forever ruin it
but instead he inflicted pain like
someone did to him
that caused him to take drugs except i
will never do drugs
because i'm stronger
i don't need to fill a void just because
i got hurt
i don't need to hurt people when they
actually helped me
and then at some point you got into the
porn industry
yeah i uh i did
um nothing much to say there it's just
like
porn isn't really real like realistic
it's like they do make a lot of money
off of it but the real thing is it's
like
filming a movie like the movie industry
cut take cut take cut take cut take pay
the people
you know just just not like
it was pretty normal
porn is like working your normal job
except i think it's like get more praise
than a normal job
you get more of money than a normal job
it's like one step down from being an
actual movie
that's how i feel about that you've been
traumatized by porn
never had anything bad happen so
i mean what is your view on the porn
industry and how it
is is it good or bad for women or for
people or men well
like i was i'm i feel like
um
porn empowers women it's uh some women
um for some women
they have had abusive relationships
abusive families
and i feel like they come into porn and
they're making money for a fresh start
so that they necessarily want to go have
sex for money on camera
so that they realize that hey look i can
save money
i can have a fresh start i can be on my
own i don't need this piece of boyfriend
i don't need this abusive family
i can literally save my money to build
my life i can build credit
i can save my money and a lot of girls
do spend their money but if they're
smart they would save it
save save save buy a house
or buy their get their own apartment
start build their credit
work on getting their car if they don't
have one try to get their permit take
driving classes so they can pass the
driver's test there's ways around
things when you're suffocating there's
always resources there's always people
willing to help to be willing to
communicate don't be afraid to ask for
help
but i do feel like porn can empower some
women
there's someone that that don't it
doesn't empower them and maybe that
wasn't meant for them
that's how i feel yeah it's certainly a
career not for everyone not for every
girl
no definitely not
but you found it empowering to some
extent
i found it kind of boring
weirdly i find that it yeah it pays good
but i found that i really at the end of
the day
i get i get kind of bored just because
it's like
not that i don't enjoy like
the times that i have to have sex is
more like i
i feel like i um
i just feel like um like it's another
job i'm doing
like no
like this is a girl in the industry her
name is emma and like i really admire
her because
she set out goals to
set aside her money
build her credit get her first
home on her own put a pull in
um like
successfully do what she's doing
take pride into it and look like she
cares about herself and
looks if she's not happy she at least
looks happy i don't know her too well at
least she looks like she's confident and
happy
she's supporting herself wait what she's
supporting herself yeah and i really
admire her and i i don't think
like i know she's she's probably a
really guarded person doesn't let people
near her and
but to be honest like i really like if i
like ever got the chance to tell her
like hey look
you're a really awesome person i really
admire you
i'd like to be a good friend to you i
could learn um from you i could really
you could really teach me like things
and i would like to like be there for
you as
a person like i remember those days she
had bad days and i text her hey
how are you doing just because i care
about people and i get worried and i see
her
upset and i just want to be like are you
okay you know is everything okay
because there's been girls in the
industry that have killed themselves and
i worry about
anybody like maybe some fans harassing
or maybe something's going on
i just want to be there for that person
it doesn't matter the person
um but i see i admire her that would be
any girl in the porn industry i'd be
there for them like no matter what
there's girls that i look after i keep
close eyes on not
just because if they're having a bad day
they they need someone to talk to
i'd be that one person to call them i
had their number i texted them if i
didn't on social media but i think
emma's achieved a lot
and i think she's come a long way and i
i think she's been in the industry for
three years and she's a really cool girl
so so your view in the industry is is
that's it's okay now i'm mutual about it
that's how i would say i my feelings are
mutual neutral
neutral yeah i don't have anything
negative
i don't have like i like i think the
positive i've already said but i don't
really have anything negative to say
um i think the only degrading part about
the industry
is when there's directors that force
girls to do things they don't want to do
and won't pay them to go home
because it's not in our contract the
contract we sign
so when they take advantage of the girls
and that's not what they're getting paid
for
and that girl's uncomfortable and
they're intimidating them because
they know they're vulnerable i don't
like that
it's the only negative thing that i
would say that's in the industry where
i've heard from other girls that
directors do do that
i haven't had that done
and if it was me someone tries to do
that i am gonna leave
it doesn't matter what you're paying me
so that's how i feel
i'm going through all this stuff that
you went through i mean what
what do you feel is the most important
lesson you've learned
a lot of the things that i went through
aren't necessarily my fault but as long
as i can accept it
i can be comfortable with myself and
move on
things happen the way they do you can't
control them
you can breathe in the moment tell
yourself it's okay
learn how to cope with it learn to move
forward be strong get back up and move
on
nothing stopping you from being a better
bigger person
going forward with your life you have to
choose to do that nobody else steps in
your shoes at the end of the day
you choose to step in your shoes and
make yourself go forward
all right maddie well thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah no problem i
wish you the best of luck
thank you thank you very much
you